The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: OK.
So this is our plan.
I'm going to talk a
bit about writing.
We're going to practice some
writing with the examples
that you uploaded and then
some other examples that
are not yours.
And then I'll talk a
little bit about hosting.
And then if we have time--
I don't know if we will--
at the end, we'll do a little
bit of hosting practice.
But part of the
hosting practice will
come with the writing practice.
It's hard to separate them.
I'm going to talk for like
maybe 10 minutes about writing.
And then we'll just get
right into the practice.
I'm going to overload you with
a bunch of guidelines or rules
or however you want
to think about it.
Don't worry about remembering
them or writing them down.
But we'll come
back to them all as
we do the practice, because
that's really how you learn,
is by doing.
This is one way to write.
It's kind of how I
approach writing.
You start with an idea.
You're like, hey, it'd be great
have a video about whatever, x.
And then the explosion
phase is the,
I'm going to think about
everything that could possibly
relate to this idea.
I'm going to write it all down.
I think you saw an example
of that with Elizabeth's snot
brainstorm.
Brainstorm is
another word for it.
And then from there,
you sort of go outward
and then you distill
it down to the essence,
like what is the actual point of
the video, who, what, how, why.
Where is sometimes
important, but not usually.
And then the stuff that we're
going to talk about today, this
is the writing piece of it.
So when you write
a script, you want
to pay attention to structure.
So what do you talk about first?
What's in the middle?
How do you end it?
That kind of thing.
Tone-- are you going for funny?
Are you going for dry?
Are you going for informal?
Are you going for formal?
Jargon-- you want to
generally try to avoid jargon,
especially if you're shooting
for high school, middle school,
that range.
By the way, it's ironic that
I'm using the word jargon.
Jargon is a technical language,
which jargon is itself
a technical word.
So that's sort of an
ironic thing there.
Visuals-- you always want to
write the script, because video
is a weird medium.
I mean, you've got
the image, and then
you've got the
soundtrack, and you
want to make sure
that they are related
and don't duplicate each other.
So that is a trick
that we'll get into.
I was reading some
of your examples
and there are particular
sentences where this is
going to be really important.
So if I don't talk about
that on my own, remind me.
Metaphors and jokes-- it's
really hard to be funny.
So if you think you can,
and you want to try,
then I would say go for it.
But generally, I
try to avoid jokes.
Metaphors are
similar, it's kind of
hard to write a good metaphor.
Do we all know what a
metaphor is, by the way?
PROFESSOR: I showed them the
[INAUDIBLE] video yesterday.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: OK, cool.
So those are sort of-- the stuff
on the left is in every video,
you've got to pay attention to.
The stuff on the right, the
metaphors and the jokes,
are sort of advanced.
Anyway, then once you sort of
get your first draft together,
you explode, you distill
that into your essence,
then you condense it, and
you write your script.
And this doesn't happen once.
This happens many, many times.
Typically, a script will
go through between 4
and like 12 revisions before
we actually shoot it, up to
and including-- we're rewriting
five minutes before we shoot.
Because you say it out
loud, and something just
doesn't sound
right, and you feel
like you have to change it.
So this is generally how
my writing process works.
Other people do it
completely differently.
This is sort of an MIT approach.
It's very sort of
structured and logical,
but it doesn't have
to be this way.
If you don't want
to write like this,
you absolutely don't have to.
The first writing guideline,
this is in addition to the flow
chart, is-- and I
think you guys talked
about this a little bit
already-- know your audience
and write for them.
And I have this note down
there, not necessarily to them.
So most of the videos that
you're going to be working for
are aimed at people
younger than you than you,
and sometimes people a
lot younger than you.
I mean, maybe even down to like
6th, 7th grade, middle school.
So you want to write to
their level of education,
but not necessarily
talk as if you were
talking to a middle schooler.
Does anyone know what I
mean by that distinction?
I'll cold call if
people don't speak up.
AUDIENCE: Like, don't baby talk?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Exactly.
Yeah, exactly.
Don't baby talk.
So give me an example of like--
pick a sentence, any sentence.
You can read it off the
intellectual property form
in front of you if you want.
But give me the non--
just the regular version.
And give me the
baby talk version,
just so we have a sense.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE ZAIDAN: No,
that's exactly right.
And you guys notice that
it's funny when he does that.
There's just
something ridiculous
about-- you call it baby talk
or talking down to your audience
or something-- that you
immediately don't pay attention
to what he's saying.
You pay attention to
how he's saying it.
And you've lost your
audience immediately.
So that's a really
important distinction.
By the way, this holds
true if you're just
interacting with kids anyway.
Most kids are smarter than
we give them credit for.
And people baby talk
kids all the time.
But if you just
straight talk to them,
you'll be surprised at the
kind of responses that you get.
Rule number two--
or guideline, sorry,
number two-- is write it
like you would say it,
because you will be saying it.
What I mean here is
your script is a draft.
And it will always be a draft.
You will never have
a final script,
because nobody's going
to log on to the internet
and read your scripts.
What they're going to do is
hear you say the words that
are on your script.
So even if a sentence
is great on paper
and you read it in your
head and it sounds awesome--
if when you say it out
loud it, it sounds weird
or it's hard to
understand or whatever,
then it doesn't matter how
great it looked on paper.
It's not an effective sentence.
This is the most important
thing we'll talk about today.
We'll come back to that
when we do the practice.
This is another version
of the previous slide.
When you-- and you
guys are all know this
because you read
scientific journal articles
and stuff-- when you read that
kind of text, it's very dense.
It's extremely well structured
and logically laid out.
It has a lot of jargon.
It's very precise.
There's very little ambiguity.
And it's understated,
and it's elegant.
Meaning like-- usually people
take the fewest possible words
to say something, and that means
using long and complex words.
And it is beautiful to read.
It's great English.
But if you try and read it out
loud and you do it on video,
again, you'll lose your
audience instantly.
It's just as bad as baby talk.
When you talk-- people talk
in-- people are very repetitive.
They say, "uh."
They say, "um."
They-- uh-- like I just did.
They don't really
use fancy words.
If their audience
doesn't understand,
they stop and they
try another approach.
It's a lot more free-form,
a lot more inconsistent,
a lot fluffier.
And that's what you
want to shoot for,
because you will be on
screen talking to the camera
as if that camera
is another person.
And so that's the write
it like you say it.
That's what I mean when I say
write it like you would say it.
Another-- and I think this
is the last guideline-- is
you really want to be accurate.
Because, obviously,
you don't want
to say things that are
wrong in your videos.
But accuracy is not the
same thing as detail.
So this is the difference
between going back
to the last slide.
Being very, very,
very precise usually
requires a lot of detail.
If you want to say
exactly what you mean,
it probably will take you a
couple sentences to say it.
But if you want to
be accurate, that
is going to-- and
especially if you
want to be accurate
for a short five minute
video-- that's going to mean
leaving information out.
And that's OK.
The test that I like
to subject scripts to
is, can an eighth
grader understand it?
If so, great.
And can a PhD In the subject
matter of that script
read the script.
And if their reaction is, wow,
this is surprisingly accurate,
then you've done a good job.
And that's all.
That's it for my rules.
Hopefully that was
less than 10 minutes.
What I want to do now is put
these rules in to practice.
We're going to start with a
quote that is not one of yours.
And then we'll move
into your scripts.
So I'm going to go ahead
and-- let me pick one.
Let's do the first one.
OK.
So let's see.
Everyone take a second
and just read this.
So you'll notice the citation.
This is from a paper.
It's written English.
Can someone just shout
out some of the rules
that would make this bad for
speaking and reading aloud?
In fact, why don't we-- let's
actually read this aloud just
to see how it sounds.
So anthropogenic CO2
emissions are contributing
to global climate change
and could negatively
impact our way of life if
serious action is further
delayed.
OK.
So what rules are
we breaking, or what
guidelines are we breaking?
AUDIENCE: I think just
hearing it out loud,
it seems kind of-- life if you
were presenting it to someone,
it'd be a long sentence.
And it's very statement.
It's not conversational.
It's not like you're-- you know,
it's not written like you would
speak.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Exactly.
What else?
AUDIENCE: The word
anthropogenic is
difficult to hear and remember.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Exactly.
It's also jargon.
It means human-made.
AUDIENCE: It's a very
passive sentence.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: It
is a very passive--
what you mean by that?
Explain.
AUDIENCE: Well, if
further delayed-- I mean,
what you really mean is
this could be troublesome.
This is bad.
Right?
Or it could be bad.
But their way of stating
as further delayed
isn't very-- it's
not a very active way
of saying the same thing.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: So here's
another interesting thing.
Negatively impact-- those
are not difficult words.
It's easy to understand
what they mean,
but let's think about
that for a second.
So what doesn't negatively
impact our way of life
mean in colloquial language?
What would you say to someone
if you were going to say,
in 100 years climate
change will do what?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Yeah.
Will it negatively
impact our way of life?
No, it's going to kill us all.
That's sort of the real-life
subtext of this sentence.
What else?
AUDIENCE: The are a lot
of complicated grammar
structures-- are
contributed, is delayed.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Mm-hmm.
You have to-- I mean, you wait
till the end of the sentence
before you get the payoff.
Right?
You don't understand what
the point of the sentence
is until you get to "negatively
impact our way of life
if serious action
is further delayed."
And really, you don't
understand-- I mean,
the point is we need to act now.
That's what this
sentence is saying.
If we act later, we're screwed.
And you don't get that until,
"if serious action is further
delayed."
So yeah, the payoff really
comes at the very, very end.
AUDIENCE: It's a fun exercise to
eliminate all of the adjectives
and look at the nouns and verbs.
Right?
Just take a second and
see if you can do that.
It actually makes
it really simple.
Emissions are contributing
to change and impact--
like picking out all of the
things that suddenly simplifies
everything-- [INAUDIBLE].
There's a lot of
descriptors in there
that are very distracting.
So now that we've
done this, let's
rephrase it as if we were
saying it to someone on camera.
PROFESSOR: Or what if just
to someone in general?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: OK, yeah,
to someone in general.
Say it to me.
Anyone.
AUDIENCE: If we don't
act now, [INAUDIBLE].
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Right.
Another version.
AUDIENCE: Man-made CO2
emissions are hurting us.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: OK.
Another.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Humans
create CO2 emissions.
We must act now or suffer.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: I like that.
That's good.
Anyone else?
Someone who hasn't
said anything yet.
AUDIENCE: If we don't
stop emitting CO2,
life will look very
different soon.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Good.
OK.
So the point I'm trying to make
by having five or six of you
say it each a different way
is that there is no one right
way to write a script.
There are lots of interesting,
engaging, dramatic ways
to say the same thing.
And we are going to
get into that now
with your examples, which
we're going to spend
considerably more time on.
PROFESSOR: Before
you move on, George.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Yes?
PROFESSOR: So it's always an
Interesting challenge balancing
avoiding being too
jargon-y and ending up
baiting your audience.
Right?
Like, there's no reason why you
can't say that words, climate
change.
Even though those are technical
terms. [INAUDIBLE] What was it?
Anthro--
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Anthropogenic.
PROFESSOR: Anthropogenic.
I mean, we talk about this
with [INAUDIBLE] scripts
all the time.
The way you deliver
a word, for instance,
can help a lot with conveying.
What was the word-- [INAUDIBLE].
GEORGE ZAIDAN: I
mean if you want
to-- if you're going to use that
same word four or five times
throughout the script, and
it's an important word,
and it relates to a
demo or something--
if there's some reason
for you to use jargon,
it's OK to define it.
As long as you just
define it like you
would to another person.
Like you say anthropogenic
means human-made.
And then you go on
and use it later on.
That's fine.
You don't want to do that
like six times in the video
and define six different
words, because then you
overload your audience.
But that's true.
There is-- if you
find yourself having
to say human-made,
man-made, woman-made.
Like if you are stretching
to try and find alternatives
to word five or six times that
you could just define and get
it over with, that's fine.
I wouldn't limit that
probably to like one or two
words a video, or
one or two words
per like three,
four minute video.
PROFESSOR: And the other reason
why it's really important
to actually do the exercise of
reading your script out lout,
or even just flipping
your script over and not
looking at it and trying
to describe the contents
to the person next to you,
is that-- a very bad habit
of mine, which I am
constantly finding
I am annoyed toward
it a lot-- is
that I get very newscaster-y.
So I may end up having a
script that sounds good
when you say it out loud.
But it sounds like
you're a reporter talking
about the latest news
update [INAUDIBLE].
CO2 emission-- can you
go back to that quote?
Yeah, like the middle
part isn't actually
that crazy to say out loud.
It's contributing to
global climate change
and could negatively
impact our way of life.
Right?
Like that doesn't sound
too crazy to say out loud.
But it sounds like someone is
saying that in the context of,
I'm here at the
MIT Course One lab
where researchers
are finding a way
to prevent global climate
change from negatively impacting
our life.
Right?
It doesn't sound
like I'm just talking
[INAUDIBLE] like a lot of
men in admissions are harming
[INAUDIBLE] life or
something like that.
I also-- [INAUDIBLE].
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Yeah.
The way you write
influences the way
you're going to
naturally say something.
And you could say this
sentence both ways.
So you could say it, you know,
anthropogenic CO2 emissions
are contributing to
global climate change
and could negatively
impact our way of life
if serious action
is further delayed.
That sounds like the
7 o'clock news, right?
You could say you
could say it like this.
Look, anthropogenic
CO2 emissions
are contributing to
global climate change.
And that could really
negatively impact our life
if we don't do
something right now.
I mean, it's basically
the same line,
but it's said two
completely different ways.
And it's much harder to say
a line like this naturally,
but it's possible.
So the way you
write can impact how
you end up saying something.
And that's important too.
We will-- whoever of
you ends up shooting
with us in the last
week of January,
we are going to guaranteed
say, no, try that again.
It sounds too new newscaster-y.
And this is a style choice,
but for Science Out Loud, it's
not news.
We don't want it to come
across like, here at MIT,
we're talking to
you about whatever.
Because MIT already
has a news office.
They do that well.
Our goal is different.
And so making that style choice
consciously from the beginning
is important.
But if you want to write
like a newscaster--
I mean, if you're
writing for a news show,
if the point of
the show is news,
then that could
be perfectly fine.
Good?
PROFESSOR: Were you going
to show the Ira Glass clip?
Later for hosting.
Yep.
It might actually be
fine to show that now
while we're talking about it.
Let we find it.
Yep, here we go.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Oh, yeah.
There we go.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Do you
guys know who Ira Glass
is-- This American Life?
He's a radio personality.
He's been doing this
for many, many years.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
IRA GLASS: I'm going to
play you a clip of tape
from my eighth year.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
IRA GLASS: [ON RECORDING]
It's not such a long way
from the local grocery store
to the international debate
over whether sorghum and meat
production are causing corn
to decline in Latin America.
There's a general
air of prosperity
here, partly thanks to
Mexican imports of US grains,
which helps boost
our farm economy.
Mexico is now one of our
biggest grain customers,
buying a half billion to $1
billion worth every year,
including corn to
feed its people
and sorghum to
feed its livestock.
Like what am I talking about?
Like, I don't even understand--
like, I wrote this.
I don't even
understand what it is.
OK, also, like every part
of this is ill conceived.
OK?
The writing is horrible.
You can't even follow
what I'm talking about.
And then the performance like--
OK, just a little tip if you're
performing for broadcast,
you don't underline
every third word for
emphasis, because it
sounds really unnatural.
What you want to do is you want
to talk the way people normally
talk.
[ON RECORDING] This helps
cut our own trade deficit
and benefits everyone
in the US economy.
But in Mexico, this
policy has lead
to fewer tortillas for the
poor and unappetizing tortillas
for everyone else.
Again, like this is
the most moronic kind
of like-- it doesn't
mean anything.
And it's hard.
It's actually kind of an
interesting story, which
I'll say to you in a sentence.
Which is, because Mexico
produces a lot of stuff
that they ship to the United
States-- tomatoes and all sorts
of really wonderful
food that we eat here--
they don't make enough
corn for their own people.
That's the story.
So for us to get
really great tomatoes,
or semi-great
tomatoes, year round,
basically, Mexicans eat worse.
That's the story.
And it's kind of an
interesting idea.
Right?
Like that's actually
sort of like a cool idea
executed in the
worst possible way.
So he's talking about
two things there.
The first is how
he wrote the story,
and the second is how
he delivered the story.
Right?
So in the second part of
the clip where he tells you
the point of the story
in like two sentences
and you can actually
understand what he's saying,
that's a writing issue.
And then the point that he
makes about, don't underline
every third word, once
you hear that-- like,
if you listen to the local news
or even the national news--
I mean, once you hear that,
you can't un-hear that.
It's incredible how
pervasive that tone is.
Because it makes
people sound very
important and official
when they choose
certain words to underline
and deliver correctly.
And, you know, that is something
that is fine for the news,
because it has a purpose.
But it's just-- I mean,
I think it's terrible.
And Ira Glass does too.
If you listen to-- his show
is called This American Life.
And if you could just
listen to the first
like three, four
minutes of any show,
it's a great example
of really good hosting.
Marketplace is another show
that has a similar style
and feel to it that's
good to listen to.
And then everything-- I think
eight minutes past the hour
or something-- NPR--
or every hour--
NPR goes back to their
local news stations.
So you can hear the difference
between newscaster-y delivery
and natural delivery.
It's a really good exercise.
Like I say, once you hear
it, you can't un-hear it.
So let's go back to writing.
What we're going
to do now is I'm
going to have-- I
picked, I think,
three or four scripts at random.
And I'm going to have whoever
wrote the script come up here
and read it.
And then we're going to do a
group critique of the script.
This is a humbling experience.
We are going to say-- we're
going to point out ways
that your script
has been better.
But that's OK.
That's how you get better.
And it's an experience
that we will go through
again and again.
Well, I won't-- because
I won't be here,
but you will with Elizabeth
again and again throughout
the rest of the course,
and especially in January.
Because we are going to be
very anal about, does this
make sense, does this convey
the idea we wanted to convey,
does it do it effectively?
So this is, I think, going to be
your first experience of that.
So who wrote that?
And by the way, I picked
random-- all right,
come on up-- I picked random
sections of the script
to talk through.
Do you want him to put on a mic?
Do you want him to wear a mic?
Yes?
Does it matter?
AUDIENCE: It doesn't matter.
OK.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: All
right, come on.
What's your name again?
AUDIENCE: David.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: David.
Nice to meet you.
I'm sorry you're going first.
All right.
So stand up there.
You can read the text here.
Deliver it like you would
like you would deliver it
if you were being recorded,
which you are being recorded.
And I'm going to
sit in your place.
And we're all going to have
a conversation about it.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] I was
sitting next to my roommate.
So I was actually kind of
shy about reading out loud.
So actually, I tried
to read out loud.
But I read it semi-internally.
So maybe that's why some of
this would sound a bit odd.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: That's OK.
No judgment yet.
Let's get it out there.
PROFESSOR: Yet?
No judgement ever.
This is a safe space.
AUDIENCE: OK.
So my topic's about why
do some people handle
cold better than others.
So why I was
interested is that, why
is it that some people are
more fearful about the cold,
that they'd rather die than
be caught outside without all
the winter gear, mask
and all, while others can
wear one layer for morning jog.
Actually, I say
yesterday morning.
And what makes all
the difference?
So the understand this,
we first need to find out
how our body reacts to cold.
The first point is that
the changes that way it
burns energy more efficient.
We actually burn
more carbohydrates
through our metabolic system
to generate more heat.
Imagine a giant furnace
within our bodies.
As winter starts
to come, we throw
more bits of carbohydrates
and start energy
to burn, and create more
heat to warm our bodies.
Then we cue pictures of
furnace and burning stuff.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: OK, great.
OK.
You can come back and sit down.
Thank you.
Excellent.
I want to point out
something that actually
has nothing to do with writing.
When you were--
very similar to how
there is a newscaster-y tone
to deliver things, especially
when you're reading
off a teleprompter,
there is also a
reading tone to deliver
things, versus reading something
out loud versus saying it
to someone.
And when you got to the end
of your first paragraph--
so you said, without all the
winter gear on, mask and all,
while others can wear one
layer for a morning jog--
I saw that yesterday actually.
Did anyone else
notice how when he
switched from
reading to talking,
you instantly
snapped to attention?
Because, I mean, here
his focus is there.
And then when he
switches over to,
I saw that yesterday, by the
way, he looks at you all.
He makes that connection with
you, and you respond instantly.
Right?
So that's something
that is maybe better
when we when we
talk about hosting,
but since you did
it right there,
I wanted to point it out.
OK, so now in one
sentence, someone
summarize the sort of
main point of this part
of the script for me.
Without re-reading
it-- sorry that
was a crucial piece
of information.
Don't read it again.
AUDIENCE: Carbohydrates
generate heat.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: OK, how?
AUDIENCE: Carbohydrates are
the fuel to generate heat.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: OK, that's
a little more specific.
Does someone else have
a different sentence
they were thinking of?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Our bodies process
carbohydrates differently,
so we react to
differently to the cold.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: OK, cool.
What technique is
used here to explain
how we process carbohydrates?
AUDIENCE: Metaphor?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Explain.
Where?
AUDIENCE: The giant
furnace within our bodies.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Does it work?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I think it makes you
understand something
that's technical and scientific
in a more relatable way.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: What do
you mean by relatable?
AUDIENCE: Well if you have
an oil furnace at home
and you're used to that thing
cranking out in the winter,
then you can kind
of relate to that.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Right.
So your body is an incredibly
complex piece of machinery.
It is basically
unlike anything else
that we're used to in our world.
But a furnace, an oil
furnace, or even a fireplace,
or whatever, something
that burns stuff,
is something that your audience
pretty much you can count on
will have seen that.
So relating this very
complex piece of machinery
to something that's much
simpler is a great way
to clue your audience in
immediately on what's going on.
We can talk about
metaphors more later
and what the tricky
parts of metaphors are,
but what else here
makes this effective?
What else makes
you want to listen?
Makes you interested
to know more?
What techniques?
AUDIENCE: Asking the question?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Yeah.
So the first paragraph
is all questions.
That's all it is. it's just
sentences of questions.
So why is that useful?
Why does that help?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] they
have to know the answer.
They [INAUDIBLE] so when
the [INAUDIBLE] speaks,
they will want to continue.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Yeah,
exactly, and that's
a really common technique.
You start with the question
with-- you start off
the video, excuse me, with
either one or more questions.
What else is effective here?
Do you want to say something?
AUDIENCE: I mean the
questions themselves work.
It's not that pose--
you could have
posed much bigger questions
like why do I get cold?
That's not a really
compelling question,
but it's a-- the
second question,
why is it that some people
are so fearful in the cold
that they would rather be
caught dead than go outside?
And when you said like
I just say this outside,
I see it outside
all the time too,
so the questions
themselves immediately
jump into relating
to the viewer.
GEORGE ZAIDAN:
And it's something
that is a common-- we didn't
talk about-- your idea should
be good, right?
But having a good idea
is an important part
of making an interesting
and readable script,
and this is something that
we've all experienced.
I mean you walk
around MIT, and you
see people walking around with
shorts in the weather outside.
It's like 12 degrees
outside or whatever.
And you think, my god,
they must be insane.
But no, maybe they actually
don't feel cold like we do.
And that is something that
is one of those things
that you see a lot, and you
don't really process it,
but when you really
stop to think about it,
you're like wow, that
is really bizarre.
I want to know more.
So you're right.
It's not just asking questions
in and of themselves,
but it's what are
those questions,
and do they point you
somewhere interesting?
What else is effective here?
AUDIENCE: There's
a "we" right there
that I feel its
absolutely essential.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Which one?
AUDIENCE: Right in the
very middle of the page,
there's-- middle,
middle, middle.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: To
understand this,
we first need to find out how
our body reacts to the cold.
AUDIENCE: That "we" I
think is so essential,
because if it were a you
or a me it wouldn't work,
but the "we" is very
appropriately engaging.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: What does it do?
AUDIENCE: I means that
you and I together
are going to figure this out.
I'm not going to
tell you, but we're
going to explore this together.
And that's the perfect
tone for this piece.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: You are
leading your audience
on an adventure
of understanding.
You're the guide,
because you're on camera,
but you're bringing
them with you-- versus
I'm just going to open
your head and dump
this information in
your head, and then
you're going to know it.
That's not what this.
This is an odyssey
of exploration
that we're going
to go on together.
Anything else that we want
to point out is effective?
OK.
What could be improved?
AUDIENCE: I think the pacing
makes it easier for the host
to read, so just have less
commas but more maybe periods,
and just split it up
into shorter sentences.
So you don't have to keep
[INAUDIBLE] for a long time.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Yeah the
sentences do get kind of long.
The last paragraph
is just two sentences
and then the middle question
in the first paragraph
is a very long sentence.
So I agree.
That's one of the
default patterns
that you fall into when
you're writing something.
When you're thinking of
something in your head,
you tend to think in sort
of long, unbroken streams
of thought, and that tends to
manifest itself on the page.
Whereas when you
talk, it may not
be sentences in the
traditional sense of-- OK,
I'm going to stop talking
now-- there's a period.
And now I'm going
to start again.
But you do have pauses
in your speech that
let your audience
understand what's going on,
and you can count
those as sentences.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Maybe
putting the metaphor
before the
scientific-- picturing
the giant furnace [INAUDIBLE].
GEORGE ZAIDAN: So
give us a version
of how you would
imagine that would go.
AUDIENCE: Imagine
a giant furnace
in the winter, burning coal
and charcoal to generate heat.
Now imagine the body,
the metabolic system
as that giant furnace.
And then the coal and
charcoal as the carbohydrates
in your food.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Yeah, great.
That's an excellent point.
So the way this
script is written,
the simple technical answer that
has no metaphor comes first,
and then you have the metaphor.
But the way that--
remind me of your name?
AUDIENCE: Kenneth.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Kenneth.
The way that Kenneth
said it is, OK-- we're
going to start simple.
We're going to start
with something you know,
a giant furnace.
Got that in your head?
Great.
Now imagine that your body
is that furnace, and instead
of coal, you've got sugar, et
cetera, et cetera, et cetera.
And you the metaphor like that,
and that's sort of a principle
of start small, start easy,
start with something you know,
and then build layer
by layer on that.
And that is something that
is not one of my rules,
but easily could be.
Everywhere except the very
first sentence of the video,
it's a great
technique to make sure
that your audience is caught
up with you all the time.
And I say everywhere
except the first bit,
because the exception
is that if you
want to start with
a compelling hook,
you might start
completely out of order,
and then come back to
something later in the video
just for the purposes
of hooking your audience
and getting them through
the first 10 seconds.
But other than that,
that sort of expansion--
I sort of look at
it as a funnel.
You start really simple,
and then work your way out
to complicated.
What else?
AUDIENCE: I'm not
really sure whether you
need the middle sentence.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Which one?
This one?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Let's try it.
So give us a read-- read
the last few lines here,
and then why don't you go
into Kenneth's version of it.
So read the last
couple of lines here,
and then go into the furnace,
and we'll see how it sounds.
AUDIENCE: Well Alice
can wear one layer
or more layers for
the morning job-- what
makes all the difference?
[INAUDIBLE] What makes
all the difference?
Imagine a giant furnace
within out bodies.
Our bodies changes and
burns energy [INAUDIBLE].
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Great.
That's perfect.
So I would agree with you-- I
think you're absolutely right.
I don't think we need
the middle sentence,
because you're
asking a question,
and then you go right
into this image.
And it's clear that
you're not immediately
answering the question,
because imagine a giant furnace
is not the answer to what
makes the difference, right?
But it's clear that, from your
tone, the way you said it-- so
you say-- what's the difference?
Well, imagine your body
is a giant furnace.
So the way that you say
something can-- essentially,
you're saying this sentence
in the tone of your voice.
So you don't actually need
to say that sentence out
loud great.
Anything else we can
eliminate by the way?
What can we cut?
AUDIENCE: I think you
already mentioned it,
but the second
sentence-- I think
you can say that a
little less wordy.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Give it a shot.
AUDIENCE: So why do
people hate the cold?
That they'd rather die than
be caught outside without all
their winter clothes on.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: So
the way you're doing
it is to sort of
piecemeal try and chop out
certain words, right?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: But
take a step back, look
at the meaning of the
sentence, reformulate it,
and just say as if you
were saying it to me.
Actually, do say it to me.
AUDIENCE: So why do
we hate the cold?
Why do some people
have to bundle up
and others don't have to wear
as much clothes, or something
like that.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Yeah, I think
you're on to something.
You walk around on a
cold winter's day--
why are some people bundled up
and some people wearing shorts?
What's the deal?
That's a much shorter way of
saying, essentially, that.
There is a
theatricality in the way
that the first
paragraph is written
that you lose by changing
it to the shorter version,
but that comes from the
benefit of you're getting
into the material faster.
But there is a trade-off there.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
You can also
accomplish all you say and
include the extra detail
with your images.
So if you show an example
of someone bundled up
with all the layers,
and then a jogger
with barely anything
other than shorts,
then you have all the content
that was in that sentence,
but you're using the
rest of the medium
that you haven't worked with.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: You
reminded me of the thing
that I was going to talk about.
Thank you.
That's exactly what I
wanted to talk about.
Yeah, so this is really
really, really easy
to forget when you're writing
a script-- is that there's
going to be a whole other
layer of information that
is available to your audience
in the final product.
So to the extent that you
can, I would absolutely
encourage use of
visuals that are
complimentary to the script.
So the way that I-- I don't have
the slides for this, but let's
say that you wanted
to show a synapse.
You guys know what a synapse is?
The part in your brain
where neurotransmitters go?
So you've got this,
this, and then-- OK.
So this is one nerve.
This is another nerve.
This is just the space
in between the nerves.
And these dots are
chemicals that this nerve
is transmitting to this nerve.
These sort of like
Poseidon spears
are receptors for
these chemicals.
Now the way that I said that--
if you were to write down
what I just said-- these
dots, this nerve, this space,
but this area is the
space between the nerve,
you'd have absolutely no
idea what I was talking
about without the image.
Whereas if you didn't
have this image,
and you were just
writing a script trying
to explain what a synapse
is, you would have to say,
a synapse is the space
between two nerves.
One nerve releases chemicals
that cross that space
and get captured by
receptors on the other nerve,
and that's how data is
transmitted from one nerve
to another.
So if you were writing a script
without the visuals in mind,
you can very easily
fall into the trap
of doing what I
just did in writing
a script that stands alone.
Whereas if you're
thinking images,
it's going to be mostly
like, look at this.
Check this out.
This spaghetti shaped
thing, those dots,
that kind of
language, and that's
totally OK and even encouraged
when you're doing a video.
And that's exactly
what you said.
Another example is to
basically talk in general terms
and put specific visuals
that compliment the script.
You were going to say something?
AUDIENCE: Yeah,
just that it's not
just that someone can
wear less clothes,
it's that they're comfortable
wearing less clothes.
And to me that's an
important concept
that we can't use in
that first paragraph.
Because my husband's
like this, where
he can be wearing
half the clothes,
and he's happy that way.
It's one thing to wear less
clothes and be miserable,
but it's another thing to be
comfortable with that choice,
right?
I see students on campus
without shoes, and I'm like,
what's going on?
But the fact that they-- it's
one thing to wear less clothes
and be shivering, and
cold, and miserable,
but it's another to
have less clothes
and actually be OK with that.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: And following
that even further--
I just had a
question in my mind.
Let's say you took two people.
One who can wear shorts
in the dead of winter,
and one who has to be
completely bundled up.
If you transport them into the
Antarctic or the Arctic where
it's-- I don't know.
Pick a really cold
temperature, subzero.
And just let them stand there
naked for like 20 days-- who
dies first?
Is it the person's
comfort, or are they
actually better adapted
to survive in the cold?
Which is a really
interesting distinction,
because if someone's
comfortable in the cold,
but they're still going to
die at the exact same time,
then yeah, comfort is great,
but we haven't, as a species,
adapted to better
overcome the cold.
Whereas if it's really
your body is substantially
different in a way that could
help the human race survive
the next Ice Age, that's cool.
So that's a really
interesting point.
AUDIENCE: And that's taking
the familiar and making
[INAUDIBLE].
It's taking an
instance that you see
and a question that maybe
you very fleetingly have,
which is how is that
some people don't have
to put on a huge winter
jacket and can walk outside
in the snow fine?
Whereas I have to layer up?
It's taking that
familiar question
and slowly building
out to this pretty epic
concept of-- are certain people
within our human race better
adapted for total catastrophe?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: I'm not saying that
you have to go that route,
but I think that
that's why watch
some of these viral videos,
because it takes the familiar
and makes it unfamiliar.
AUDIENCE: It also-- I
mean, not to totally go
a different route--
but a question
that this could go into is
are skinny people versus
fat people-- does
it have anything
to do with your physical being?
Or is it your
chemical being that
makes you be able to handle
the situation better,
and can you change that?
Or is it just how you're built?
AUDIENCE: But if you
tighten this first part up,
it leaves you the
room to explore
the really cool questions.
We could easily cut all
this text down into half
it's length.
Why do some people handle
the cold better than others?
How is it that this person
who's wearing shorts in winter
is fine, whereas this person
is wearing five jackets?
What's making the difference?
Well, imagine a giant furnace.
That furnace is actually us.
You're taking out the
whole middle chunk.
I also think you can highlight
the unexpected nature
of the furnace metaphor right?
You're taking the
familiar ones, and you're
entering the unfamiliar.
Imagine a furnace--
everyone can picture that--
but the crazy thing is that
our bodies are furnaces.
We kind of did that
with the [INAUDIBLE].
And then the whole end--
and winter starts to come
and we throw more
bits of carbohydrates
and stored energy.
Carbohydrates and stored energy
are similar enough things
that you can distill it
down into one phrase.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Sugars.
AUDIENCE: Sugars, yeah.
But by tightening all
of this intro stuff
up into two concepts,
it leaves you
the rest of the episode to
explore the cooler questions.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: And then you
can go with-- the metaphor,
you can take as far as you want.
You can say, OK, well,
are some people's furnaces
more efficient?
Do some burn different
types of sugar?
Whatever the answer
ends up being-- I
don't actually know
what the answer is.
I really want to know,
but whatever that is,
you can develop the
metaphor or not, depending
on whether it fits
and really explore
this question that's fundamental
to the nature of our survival,
because there will
be another Ice Age.
It's coming.
We just don't know when.
So we took this experience
that we've all had,
and we turned it into an
existential crisis, which
is great.
So thank you.
Next, I was going to do two
examples from each script,
but I think we should just move
on, because we're running short
on time.
Whose script is this?
All right, come on up.
All right, so you
know the drill.
Give us a read.
AUDIENCE: Once upon a
time, in the year 2009
actually, Stephen
Hawking held a party
with all the usual stuff--
wines, hors d'oeuvres,
and yet no one turned up!
And you'd have
thought he'd be upset,
but in fact, he was
actually quite happy,
because it just proven
his own belief that it
was impossible to
travel back in time.
He had, in fact, sent
out the invitations
for the party to time travelers
after the party had-- I already
mentioned it.
A lack of partygoers
actually meant
that time travel was
probably impossible,
or just that people thought
that Stephen Hawking was lame
and didn't really want
to go to his party.
So was time travel
really not possible?
Yeah.
GEORGE ZAIDAN:
Great, come on back.
So what is effective
in this script?
Introduction, really--
It's not a full script.
Yeah, you have to
raise your hand.
Just yell it out.
AUDIENCE: Well he introduces
a character who we know,
but he's doing this party
thing that's just like us.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: So we all
love Stephen Hawking.
If you don't, leave immediately.
So right off the bat,
Stephen Hawking is invoked,
and that's great.
Now we know exactly who
we're talking about.
We're all on the same page, and
we all love Stephen Hawking.
At least your audience
for this video
is most likely going to know
and love Stephen Hawking?
Not everyone does.
AUDIENCE: And even
if they don't, it's
still a cool enough premise.
This one's doing the opposite--
taking something unfamiliar,
and you're going to spend
the adventure familiarizing
yourself with it.
That someone had
a party intending
to have no one show up, because
he was proving time travel.
It's like this pop
culture fascination.
It's very Hollywood science.
It's the reason why so many of
the special effects that you
have on TV and so much
of the science that does
end up broadcasting
on major networks.
They're all about
astrophysics stuff,
and it's because it's
commercializable?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: It's just cool.
Who here has watched Cosmos?
New or old?
New?
Both?
At one point in one
of the episodes,
either Carl Sagan, or Neil
deGrasse Tyson, or probably
both say that we have this
inbuilt fascination looking up
at the stars and wondering what
our place is in the universe,
and that is absolutely true.
And shows and movies capitalize
on that all the time.
Interstellar, Gravity, are
two of the most recent ones,
but we've always looked
up, and wondered,
and written stories about it.
What else works?
So what's instantly
different about this script?
This introduction versus
the last introduction?
AUDIENCE: Something visual
that [INAUDIBLE] something
very visual.
In my mind, I'm thinking of
this sad face, smiley face.
It's going to be quite funny.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Take
that even further.
It's visual, but
it's also-- When
Kenneth got up here
and started talking
to you, what was he doing?
AUDIENCE: He was
[INAUDIBLE] face?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: He
was what, sorry?
Yeah, he was expressive, right?
AUDIENCE: He used his
[INAUDIBLE] and [INAUDIBLE].
GEORGE ZAIDAN: But
even before that.
"Once upon a time," what's that?
Once upon a time.
It's a story.
You're telling a story.
And eventually, in this
intro-- this is also a story
that you're telling,
but once upon a time
is right off the bat, everybody
knows that's story time.
And just like we're hard-wired
to sort of look up at the stars
and wonder where
we came from, we're
hard-wired to love stories.
When you start a sentence
with once upon a time,
you're listening.
AUDIENCE: But that doesn't
necessarily mean you should.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Again, take everything
we say with a grain of salt.
It's not the tools that you
use that make things work,
it's the reason why
you use the tools.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: So you don't have
to say once upon a time here
to know that it's a story.
Because even if you
didn't say, you'd say,
in 2009, Stephen
Hawking held a party.
No one showed up,
but he was thrilled.
Why?
Because he'd just
proved time travel.
Let me explain to
you how that works.
Blah, blah, blah, blah.
I didn't say once
upon a time, but even
though I didn't say it,
my first two sentences
are still this like, click--
I'm going to tell you a story.
What else is effective?
Actually effective or
what you would improve.
AUDIENCE: I think
the last sentence
kind of throws a loop in.
I'm unsure about what the
body of it is going to be,
because you take this really
smart guy like Stephen Hawking.
He just proved that you
can't travel back in time.
So is this going to
explain why that's true?
Or it's just the
next breakthrough
where it actually is true.
I'm kind of unsure what's
going to happen next.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Anybody
else a little bit--
are you saying that as
something that works
or something that
could be improved?
AUDIENCE: To clarify, i guess.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Was
anybody else a little bit
hazy on where the
script is going,
or what's been said already?
Yeah?
So when I read this, I
was a little bit confused.
So what's the answer
to this question?
Tell me in a couple sentences.
AUDIENCE: And what
happens after?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Summarize
your script for me
in two or three sentences.
AUDIENCE: After that, we talk
about what time travel is
and how it's maybe
possible to time travel,
and why, theoretically, it's
not possible to do it yet.
[INAUDIBLE]
Maybe we just haven't
explored enough yet.
We don't understand enough of
the [INAUDIBLE] time travel.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: So the bottom
line, main point of the video
is we're not sure if
time travel is possible?
AUDIENCE: That currently
it points to the fact
that we are unable.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: But most
science says that it's not
going to be possible?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: So we think it's
not going to be possible ever?
AUDIENCE: But yet
we're still asking.
We're questioning [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: I think to fix
that, instead of maybe prove
by-- I don't know--
you could just
take a less qualifying word
like the possibility that he has
disproven it, or something
that gives him some sort of air
that there is the possibility
that it isn't true.
I don't know.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: So
let me ask you--
without going back to
this intro, tell me again
the underlying theory
behind the party,
and what it proves
that no one showed up?
Or doesn't prove, or
we think, or whatever.
AUDIENCE: Prior to this,
Hawking has said [INAUDIBLE],
but he believes that
it's not possible.
So he set up this
extra experiment.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: He believes that
time travel is not possible?
AUDIENCE: So he set up
this extra experiment.
He hosted the party.
It fails on [INAUDIBLE].
Then he sent out
invitations after the party
to time travellers.
So he even included specific
coordinates and specific date
and time.
So when no one showed
up, [INAUDIBLE] so it's
not possible.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: I see, OK.
Now I get it.
So when you read the
script the first time--
whose understanding
of the script
changed based on hearing
that explanation.
I must say that I actually know
this point, but reading this
I didn't understand,
until I [INAUDIBLE].
And it actually happens to
be a Big Bang Theory joke.
A Big Bang Theory joke
where they sat together,
and they said, let's
swear to this day
that we will come back
to this exact same moment
if we do invent a time machine.
And then they wrote this
letter and swore on it,
and they waiter for one
second and no one came.
And they were really sad.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: So that's
another version of the same?
So now I totally get this.
Let's think about other
creative ways to--
AUDIENCE: I don't.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: You don't.
I still don't get it.
I'm sorry, but I
still don't get it.
I don't understand the concept
that he sent invitations
after the party and
no one showed up?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: So someone else
explain it in a different way
than has already been explained.
AUDIENCE: So it's like if
I were to swear to myself
right now that in the future,
if I do invent a time machine,
I will come back
to the time when
I'm writing this right now.
So theoretically
speaking, that would
mean that as I'm writing
this, my future self
will come right now.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: But actually,
now that you say that,
that brings up a really
interesting point.
Your version just
proves that you're not
going to invent a time machine.
But Kenneth's version
proves that no one--
AUDIENCE: All the time
travelers possible that he sent
would not be able to--
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Sorry.
So Kenneth's version
proves that everyone
that Stephen Hawking
sends an invite to
will not invent a time machine.
It doesn't necessarily
prove that no one will ever
invent a time machine.
It's just an interesting point.
AUDIENCE: There was also
a time travel [INAUDIBLE]
in the '90s on East Campus.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: So this happened?
AUDIENCE: At MIT.
So that's just another
thing that you should note.
Other people have tried to do
it, and that's [INAUDIBLE].
But also, it's nicer that
MIT students [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: That's a good
example, but we're still
missing what the
big-- we're coming up
with examples and accessories
when we don't have
the core point of the video.
And I think I really feel
like taking the last question,
completely scrapping it,
and trying to figure out
how to best set up the
rest of the episode
is what's going to
help you the most.
When you explained all
that stuff to me, I
Totally read your intro
completely different.
And the question that I
came up with in my head
before you asked your
question-- so you
read through the whole thing.
You said, or maybe
Stephen Hawking
was too lame-- my initial
question as an audience member
was, OK, well then
how did he prove that?
Like how did that
party prove it?
And if it did prove it, why
are we still asking ourselves
if time travel is possible?
I guess that's how
I initially reacted,
and that sets up a very,
very different episode
than the question that's
up there right now.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: I
also want to give--
so this kind of
discussion is exactly
the kind of discussion that
happens with every script
that we do for Science Out Loud.
And I know it seems
like we're piling on,
but I really want to give
you props for taking a chance
and doing this sort
of creative intro,
because we're going with this,
I think is really interesting.
So your two questions at the
end are-- what were they again?
It was?
AUDIENCE: It was how did
this actually prove it?
And if it's proven, why are
we still asking ourselves?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Yeah.
So if we could have
an infinite party,
where we send out infinity
invitations to everybody
on the planet in the
future, would that
prove-- and then no one
shows up at this party--
would that prove that
time travel is impossible?
So let me back up.
I'm going from the Big Bang
example, which is-- or no,
actually your example.
Which is you
proving to yourself.
You say, all right, if I
invent a time machine then
I swear to myself I'm going
to come back to this moment.
I don't come back, so I
didn't invent a time machine.
Then to Kenneth's
version-- Stephen Hawking
sends an invitation to
let's say 20 people.
No one shows up?
That means those 20 people
didn't come back in time.
AUDIENCE: Actually, it was
more like an open invitation
to the future.
It's [INAUDIBLE].
The fact that he had the party.
So in the future,
[INAUDIBLE] time
travel anyone who would
[INAUDIBLE] know of this party.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: But
conceivably, you could-- I
get what you're saying.
I think, as a
thought experiment--
you're going to miss
somebody in your invite,
if you send out a finite
number of invitations,
no matter how broad
your spectrum is.
But I mean you could pick
something in-between where
you send out a million
invites, but there are still
7 billion people on the planet.
So then the question
is, if you send out
if you've sent an invitation to
not just everybody who's alive
right now, but
everybody who will ever
be born from this moment
forward-- everybody,
whatever number of billion or
hundreds of billion of people
that is.
Theoretically, if someone
invents a time machine
and decides to go to your party,
they would come back in time
and go to your party.
So then if you set that story up
with the audience-- and that's
a long set up.
You've got three
separate scenarios--
between one and three, you
could do two scenarios.
It's a long set up, but
the story element of it
means that your audience
will probably stick
with you, especially because
it's an unusual story.
It's like a weird
thing, and there's
confusion at the beginning.
You're saying, like,
hold on, I didn't get it.
Your audience is going to be
in that space for the first 30
seconds of the video.
And there's a fine line
between I don't get it--
I'm going to turn
off this video,
and I don't get
it-- I'm interested;
I want to keep watching.
But if you can stay on the
line of I'm interested;
I'm going to keep
watching, the I
don't get it can be
an OK thing to do.
And then after that, you get
into Elizabeth's question
of what does this thought
experiment actually mean?
And does it does
it prove anything
and how do we know, which I
think is a fascinating video.
Conceptually, I think
it's really hard,
the double negative.
To either choose to say is
time travel possible or not
the opposite, which is
time travel not-- it's
just harder to conceptualize.
So when you do go
down this road,
I would just see if you could
take the affirmative approach,
which is time travel possible.
AUDIENCE: I would wait to
ask that question though,
because that's actually not
the question that's relevant.
The question is how
did that prove it?
Then the next question is why
are we still looking, and then
the immediate question
that [INAUDIBLE] is time
travel possible?
That sets the core
question, but it
doesn't show up at-- it's
too big to [INAUDIBLE].
GEORGE ZAIDAN: This is great.
This is a fascinating
discussion.
Good job.
Anything else before
we move on here?
AUDIENCE: So there was
a bit of discussion
where there was a detail
on how many people
Stephen Hawking actually
sent out an invitation to,
but that kind of
detail doesn't really
affect the knowledge that
you're trying to disseminate.
Is it OK if we were to--
because it's not really
an official history
point, so I'm not sure
whether I'll be allowed
to deviate from it.
GEORGE ZAIDAN:
That's a great point.
In writing your scripts, you
will generate more material
than you'll use.
And probably going through--
I had the three scenarios.
Probably the middle scenario
is just not worth doing,
because it takes
up a lot of time,
there are a lot of
subtleties to it--
how many invitations
exactly, who
gets the invitations,
et cetera, et cetera
that is not important for the
subject matter of the video.
So being able to edit yourself
or edit others on that stuff
is really good.
So yeah, absolutely,
great point.
AUDIENCE: You can also
gloss over it pretty fast.
You can be like,
OK, so when you're
explaining the actual
details of the party,
you say he sent out an open
invitation, no one came,
so the conclusion was that no
one invented a time machine.
Well I guess you could say
maybe someone in Antarctica
wasn't aware of
the open invitation
so that's why they didn't come.
So what if we could ensure that
every single human being on
will ever exist in the future
somehow got this invitation?
Then will the argument
still hold up?
Then you're glossing over
each incremental example
and addressing the crux
of the loophole that's
in that scenario.
AUDIENCE: Also, I
wanted to mention humor.
So saying that Hawking was too
lame-- while the other humorous
parts are very
effective, that one
may be kind of edgy,
especially for people
who don't know who Hawking is.
Maybe like, uh-oh,
this person is lame,
and people who do
know him will--
GEORGE ZAIDAN: So
that reminds me
of your earlier point--
which is that this actually
happened at MIT.
[INAUDIBLE] time
[INAUDIBLE] going.
And one of the things
that we try and do
with the Science Out Loud videos
is establish a relevant MIT
connection.
And so that would be a
great way to do that,
and then you get around the
whole Stephen Hawking thing.
AUDIENCE: I like the
humor point, though.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: I do too.
AUDIENCE: The word lame
maybe is not as PC.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
completely forgot.
AUDIENCE: But the whole concept
of what other possibility--
GEORGE ZAIDAN: But
maybe Stephen Hawking's
rival just didn't want
to show up to spite him.
Maybe he's like, well, I've
invented a time machine,
but I'm not going to let you
know about it, because I'm
too cool for you or whatever.
There are ways to get
that exact same humor
thing without using lame.
But I like it.
I like it too.
Anything else?
Cool.
Whose is this?
All right, come on up.
AUDIENCE: So as long as people
have lived on this planet,
there have been boats.
Many of the model boats
shown in this museum-- this
is at the ship museum at
MIT-- are over 100 years old,
but evidence suggests that
the oldest ones date back
to log boats, almost
10,000 years ago.
But now, when we look
onto the hardware,
it is clear that
we have advanced
since the times
of hollowed trees.
Today, there are
all types of ships,
such as container ships, oil
tankers, and cruise ships,
among others.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Great, thanks.
OK, what works?
Actually, we're not going
to-- just comments in general?
Good, bad, whatever.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: It feels a
lot like a documentary.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: What
do you mean by that?
AUDIENCE: The image I get
walking through a museum
and look around
us-- I don't know.
That's the feel I get.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Uh, what's
you're question?
AUDIENCE: So what three was--
it kind of gets to that.
So I think you're right.
There is a lot of words before
I get to what I'm presenting.
GEORGE ZAIDAN:
Tell us what it is.
AUDIENCE: So it's about
subdivision in ships.
So if you take something
that floats, like a shoebox,
and you put a hole
in it, it'll sink.
But if you divide that shoebox
into watertight sections,
this one compartment might
not cause it to sink.
And how we've been asked
to-- the time where
a ship can be
extensively damaged
and can still stay afloat
and people won't die.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: What
you just did right
there is a fantastic
pitch for a video.
Like the way that you
explained it to us right now.
You get into the
subject matter quickly.
Use you use something that we're
all familiar with, shoebox.
You start simple
and you expand out.
You start with a shoebox,
expand out to a ship.
And you have the potential
for an example that
is super relatable, like
that Italian cruise-- was
it an Italian cruise
ship that didn't sink,
but it turned sideways-- you
could use something like that.
I'm sure there's a more
appropriate example.
But you just add that, and you
have the perfect pitch and also
a great introduction
to a video too.
AUDIENCE: I also really liked
what he says in the second part
where he says he's a coast
guard marine inspector
and naval architect,
a ship designer,
and he [INAUDIBLE]
sleep over the subject.
So that to me
sounds pretty cool.
First of all, those
are awesome jobs,
and also, you are
saying that you
have an emotional connection.
You're an expert in [INAUDIBLE].
GEORGE ZAIDAN: And the
other thing is that we
don't-- Science Out Loud doesn't
put random people on camera.
Whoever we put on
camera is going
to have some connection
to the material,
whether it's this is my
lab that we're working in,
or I am a member of the Coast
Guard or whatever it is.
And highlighting that in a
way that is not newscaster-y.
That's hard to do,
but highlighting
that can really draw the
audience into the material.
AUDIENCE: A lot better
than poached eggs.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
GEORGE ZAIDAN: So honestly, if I
were you, I would cut the intro
and go with what you just said.
The other nice thing
about what you said
is that you can do it
with a shoe box in front--
it's a demo you can do.
So it has a visual that goes
along with it really easily.
AUDIENCE: And since
you're actually
doing that, there's potential
for a really big visual reveal,
where we have you
frame with the shoebox,
and then cut you to wide
shot, and reveal you
in front of an actual ship.
So there's a lot of potential
to play with the visuals there.
Where you don't have
to say all the boats
here-- we don't even
have to go in the museum,
we can actually go
to wherever you work.
But I agree with
George that-- when
you were talking about
the shoebox stuff,
I didn't even realize that
that was a question that I had,
but then you made me
think, just like how
David made me think
about the whole
why do some people feel
colder than others.
How does a giant ship not sink
if there's a little hole in it?
Whereas on a toy boat,
if there's a hole,
then it's just catastrophe.
GEORGE ZAIDAN:
Another question I
have about ships is that--
you see a giant cruise liner,
and a, what percentage
of it is underwater?
Is it 10% or is it 50%?
And b, how the hell does
that thing not just tip over?
AUDIENCE: We actually
just asked that yesterday.
So you're wondering?
Yeah there is a
lot of draft on it,
so the distance below the
waterline is substantial,
so it's not uncommon to be 40
to 60 feet under the water.
But they fin stabilizers which
they use when a lot of people
are on board.
They're just pretty much wings
that go on the side of a ship.
And with that, they're able
to adjust their attitude
to provide a more
comfortable draft.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Are
they like wings
like as big as a airplane wing?
Or is it shorter?
AUDIENCE: They're a
little bit shorter,
and they're kind of stubbier,
but they have pretty good--
GEORGE ZAIDAN: So if you took
a cruise ship out of the water,
it would look like a
deformed penguin kind of?
AUDIENCE: I guess you could
think like [INAUDIBLE].
Most have-- newer
ones all have them.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: This is
again that idea explosion
phase, where you're talking
about compartmentalization,
and that's the
core of the video.
But there may be
other things that-- I
don't know if this
would actually make it
into your video or not, but that
is something that you wonder
when you look at a cruise ship.
Like how does that thing
possibly stay afloat?
Is most of the mass underwater?
AUDIENCE: I can't really
say quantitatively.
I'm not sure, but I know that
that's one of the big parts
of it, is having appendages that
are able to reduce the roll.
So if you have a
cylinder, and it's water,
and you're trying to pitch
it or just have it roll,
it's going to go forever, but
if you put these two wings on,
the inertia of
actually rolling it
is a lot harder, because it
has these arms sticking out.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: I
think you've actually
got material for two
separate videos in there.
I think the compartmentalization
is one really--
it could be a short video.
It doesn't have to be long.
And then there's this whole
other-- boats, and ship
building, and how
do these things,
how do these giant--
because they've
gotten big enough now
that you can have 2,000
or 3,000 people on a ship.
How do these things stay afloat?
It'd be really cool, I think.
AUDIENCE: From an educational
context point of view.
With the K-12 videos program
in its old iteration,
where people made
their own episodes,
there were like 10
episodes on buoyancy.
I don't know why people are so
obsessed with explaining it,
but I think it's because it's
a topic that maybe people
struggled with in school.
AUDIENCE: No, it's
a framework test.
So, second graders-- it's
the essential question that
is asked in the curriculum.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Buoyancy?
AUDIENCE: Yes, sink or float.
What sinks, what
floats, and why?
And it's a questions
that's intended to get
them thinking scientifically.
And so that big
buoyancy question
is-- when I was learning
to be a teacher,
that was the core question, even
in schools that had no science
curriculum whatsoever.
At that age, that's
when they begin
asking scientific questions,
and that experiment
is something you need to
do, no matter where you are.
You have a small bucket.
Any kid can do it,
regardless of what class.
I taught in some
inner city schools
where there no resources,
but you can still
do that experiment.
AUDIENCE: Do they figure
out at that age-- do they
why a sinkable object like
steel would float, or something?
AUDIENCE: Well the
idea is that students
can construct themselves with
themselves by experiment.
So the teacher, if
it's a great teacher,
will put a bucket of water
and a whole bunch of objects.
And encourage
students to eventually
come up with some truths
themselves about what sinks
and what floats through
hands-on experimentation.
And that's sort the crux of the
most early science exploration
in our curriculum, which is
why there's so much on sink
and float, and that's why
the kids were all-- they
all were interested in
that when you talk to them,
because it was
drilled into them,
at least in our educational
system, the idea of sinking
and floating and a very
elementary concept that
is the beginning of
their scientific roots.
AUDIENCE: But the
reason why I bring it up
is that there are 100 videos
on sinking and floating,
and they're all the
exact same thing.
And every lesson
on buoyancy-- you
learn it in more
detail in high school.
It's still on the same thing.
And this is
presenting it in a way
that's very, very different.
And I hesitated to
bring it up at all,
because I don't want you
to look at those videos,
and I don't want you to
look at the standards
and accidentally
default to that style.
I think you should totally keep
going the way you're going.
I only wanted to
bring it up, because I
think that there is
definitely an appetite for it
in an educational context.
I also wanted to
bring up that-- it's
funny-- I wish we could have
the raw footage from all
the classes just to [INAUDIBLE],
because when you explain
the technical components
of the wings and stuff--
we could've used that footage.
And it's very different from
when you read this aloud.
And the script also
doesn't sound like you
at all, when you talk.
And it's a very
difficult thing to do.
I sympathise with
you guys completely.
It's really hard to
become self-aware
of your natural talking style.
And so some of it
will be just-- maybe
you want to record a
conversation that you
have with someone else.
That might not be the
best thing for everyone.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: One of
the things you could do
is instead of recording yourself
on camera, record just audio.
Because the visual
part of it-- like
if you're conscious that
there's a lens looking at you,
it's very hard to be natural.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and
I'm not very good
in front of a lens or anything.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Getting
rid of that misconception
is a whole other thing.
We'll get into it in a
second, but it's much easier
to just be yourself if
you just have a mic,
and you're not really--
you sort of forget
that the mic is there.
You're not looking into
a lens or whatever.
So having that, it's easier
to record yourself and hear
what you really sound
like if you just use
audio, versus video as well.
AUDIENCE: So say you're
trying to simplify something,
a complicated concept, so
you're talking to [INAUDIBLE],
and there's a lot of
different technical reasons
that you have these
fin stabilizers.
So just being able to
say that this is stopping
the ship from
rolling, it's true,
but there's other aspects to it.
So this gets into
the accuracy portion.
Like you could have a naval
architect go on K through 12
and be like, yeah, but
there's more to it than that.
So at what point are
you oversimplifying.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: I think there's
no harm in alluding to the fact
that there are that
you are just at the tip
of the iceberg of information.
So you could say
something like-- the way
you said it was if you take
a cylinder, put it in water,
and spin it, it'll spin.
You take a cylinder, attach
some wings, put it in water--
it's much harder to spin it.
That is all 100%
accurate and true,
but you don't get into any
of the technical reasons
as to why that's the case.
That's one way to do it.
The other way to do
it is if you want
to start talking about whys.
And I don't know what the whys
are, so you have to help me,
but you can start off
your senses with-- look,
this is a really simple
way of explaining it,
but basically, blah, blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
So you just sort of
allude to the fact
that I'm giving you the
super simple version of it.
It's much more complicated
than this in real life.
And you can even explain
what those complications are.
So if you had wings with
a bunch of holes in them,
they wouldn't be as
effective as solid wings,
because x, y, or z.
Or if your ship's
wings need to be
able to do this and that
for whatever reason--
you can allude to stuff
without actually explaining it,
and that's OK, because
you do that in real life.
If you're sitting across
the table from someone
and explaining something to
them, the first time you do it,
you're not going to be like--
roman numeral I, part a,
subsection b-- you're not
going to go super in-depth.
You're going to be like look,
here's the important thing
to get right now.
Here are some of the details.
We can about the details later,
but this is the crucial thing.
AUDIENCE: So more of the
result and not everything
that got to that result?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: I don't
know that I would--
AUDIENCE: Or if it's
a little too tricky,
then mention it, but focus
on what the main reason
why they're there.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Yeah.
I think just being conscious
of the fact that what you're
presenting isn't all
of the information,
it is an accurate portion
of the information.
AUDIENCE: And
that's actually what
we want with Science Out Loud.
And keep in mind, it's
a very different style
than some of the
other videos that i
was talking about on
the first day of class.
But we want to pique curiosity.
We want people to finish
watching the video
and ask themselves
those questions
and try to figure
it out on their own
and explore the other resources.
And that's a very
different objective
than say a lecture video
or a technical video.
So just keep that in mind.
Again, whatever best practices
we're establishing here
aren't necessarily
ones that you'll
carry over to every
single educational video.
We encompass such a
huge variety, right?
But I think that's true of
even the most technical video.
And again, this goes back to the
whole rabbit hole witness test.
Once you find yourself
clarifying more and more
to the point where
you found yourself
on a topic that is tangential
to the main point of your video
or the main point
of your lesson,
then it's time to backtrack
a little bit, and that's OK.
No video under an hour.
No semester-long class
is going to answer
every single question
that's related
to the topic of the class.
AUDIENCE: But this gets
back to what we were
talking about the [INAUDIBLE].
By going deeply and
narrowing your focus actually
allows you to allude to a
lot of much larger topics
superficially.
And people get it more
quickly the more narrow
you are in your examples.
And think if there were a
truth in here, that's the truth
to sort of apply-- is that
the more specific and narrow
you can be without
getting [INAUDIBLE]
in that extra
information, the easier it
is to allude to that
extra information
without it-- like
a story flow, you
want it always more forward.
And if this information
is so little
that it doesn't prevent
the forward motion
of your storyline, then
you know you're doing
a good job of including that.
What you don't want is
for this information
to take you backwards
or sideways.
AUDIENCE: I mean I guess I
should rephrase that it's not
necessarily a rabbit hole.
You don't want to
branch out too much.
You want accuracy, specificity
to a certain degree.
You could very well do a
video on why do boats float,
but that wouldn't
really be a good video.
It wouldn't be a very
compelling video.
So you're going to make a video
about the wings on a boat.
You're going to hit the bigger
topic of how things float,
but that's not the thing that's
driving your video forward.
AUDIENCE: And that's
why your topic
is perfectly narrow
of imagining three
differently smooshed shoeboxes.
Why does this one versus
this one-- and it's
a narrow enough topic,
and concrete enough
that it will allow you to
get to some of those bigger
sink or float buoyancy
design issues.
But using this very small way
of getting access to that.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: By
the way, I wanted
to come back to something
that is a tad tangential,
ironically.
You said, maybe it's better
then to just tell the results
and leave out the process.
And I said no, maybe not.
The reason that I said
no is because sometimes,
taking your audience through
the experimentation that
was done to get to
a result is just
as interesting or
even more interesting
as the result itself.
So the Stephen Hawking example--
the time travel experiment
and the intricacies of
are just as interesting,
to me, anyway,
as the result of that
experiment, whatever it is.
So that's why I would just
caution against using that.
Sometimes-- how did
people first invent
compartmentalizing boats?
I'm not saying that is
an interesting answer.
It may not be.
But sometimes that process is
just as interesting as the fact
that there are compartmentalized
boats and why they work.
AUDIENCE: One thing
that I mentioned--
I don't know if
it's worth exploring
is the whole reason why
[INAUDIBLE] was like I know
that floating is obviously
a big teaching point,
but if you open with
why the Titanic sank,
which has exactly to do
with compartmentalization,
is that something that
would be a better hook?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: I honestly
like your shoebox better.
I'll tell you why--
because it's more visual.
Sorry, it's more visual
because it has you in it.
There's a demo.
There's a thing that
someone can look at,
and it's directly accessible.
With the Titanic,
yeah, it's an example
that everyone knows,
and you could maybe
use stock footage of the
movie Titanic or whatever.
But it's one degree
of complexity--
it starts at a higher
level of complexity
than your shoebox example.
AUDIENCE: Well I'm
saying you could do--
GEORGE ZAIDAN: First
shoebox, then Titanic?
AUDIENCE: No, how the Titanic
did their compartmentalization
with a shoebox.
So they didn't finish
their [INAUDIBLE]
to the deck, which you
could actually easily
build with a shoebox,
and then just see
how it progressively floats.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: So the
problem with the Titanic
was that their
compartments did not extend
all the way through the hull?
AUDIENCE: All the way
up the [INAUDIBLE].
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Why?
That seems dumb.
AUDIENCE: I have no idea.
AUDIENCE: But then
the video becomes
about why did the
Titanic sink, instead of
about how do I prevent boats
from sinking as a Coast Guard.
AUDIENCE: I think
it's distracting.
I think it's
distracting, and I think
that the simplicity
of this shoebox
allows you to gain
access to the concepts
more easily, without getting the
story of the Titanic entangled
into it.
AUDIENCE: The other thing
is, if you are not at MIT
studying naval
architecture or whatever,
and if you weren't actually
an engineer, just maybe
Vsauce or hand Hank
Green, then I'd
say, yeah, talk about
why the Titanic sunk.
But it's a story that's
already been told.
And it's a story that
can be told by anyone.
You have this
opportunity to tell us
a story from a perspective
that not many very people can,
and that's what I
was trying to get out
on the first day about being
able to take yourself out
of the perspective that
you're used to having.
I think that is an opportunity
to capitalize upon, for sure.
So it's not that I think
that the Titanic thing is
a bad hook, necessarily--
just that the one you have
is so much better.
And one that not
other people can do.
AUDIENCE: Can I
also say that you
had mentioned about process.
In my lab, the work that
I see predominately-- I
would actually argue that it's
extremely hard for scientists
to share a process in
an interesting way.
That scientists, typically--
and I am generalizing,
and this is not really fair, but
because we spend so much time
day-to-day going
through a process,
you want to share
it chronologically,
and that's where your default
is to go from start to finish,
telling people what you
did in painstaking detail,
and that's boring.
And so that's really,
really hard-- if any of you
end up doing a process where
you're sharing your process,
it's really hard to figure
out the bigger picture
within the process so
that an outsider actually
finds your process
interesting, as opposed
to just sharing the I did
this, then I did this,
then I did this.
Explaining why I did
what I did each way
is what people care about.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Well
the interesting part
is the moment of ingenuity that
led to an experiment designed
the way it was designed.
Not the day-to-day--
AUDIENCE: Exactly, and I
feel like because people
in their labs are like
someone needs to listen to me.
I did this.
It didn't work, and I spent
hours and hours working on this
and it didn't work.
They feel like they want
to share that with people,
but people don't
actually care about that.
They care about the
why you designed
the experiment that way,
and why it didn't work,
as opposed to the
what you actually did,
the who cares kind of concept.
AUDIENCE: Actually, I agree
with you on the Titanic idea,
but you mentioned that you could
build these compartments out
of shoeboxes, and I think
that at least the kids that we
talked to yesterday--
they really
like the idea of destruction.
Something burning,
being crushed.
So if you could kind of
talk about those concepts
and in the end, you
sink some random ship.
That would kind of show,
first of all, that it's cool,
but also it shows that what
you;re talking about is
important.
AUDIENCE: Don't get me wrong.
You can totally
bring up the Titanic
at the end as the bigger
picture application.
That's awesome.
It's just the hook
isn't the place for it,
I think personally.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: It's
been done before.
I agree with you.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Great.
Anything else on this script?
Going once, going twice--
AUDIENCE: Before you
go onto the next one,
I do just want to
mention-- sorry.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: I'm
just kidding, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I do want to
mention that you guys came up
with really fascinating topics.
I mean George and I were
talking about it this morning.
So I mean even though
we're critiquing things,
the topic at the
core, I think there's
a lot of potential for it.
So just a word of encouragement.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Yeah,
I would totally
watch all of these videos.
AUDIENCE: I don't know
where we're going quite yet,
but we've been
going for a while.
I suspect people might
need a bathroom break.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Oh
yeah, good idea.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I
need a bathroom break.
AUDIENCE: So maybe we
should, before we dive
into the next one give people a
chance to stretch and do that.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Yeah,
OK, who wrote this?
GUEST SPEAKER: I'm cold.
AUDIENCE: I'm warm.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: I'm
pretty warm, yeah.
AUDIENCE: I think it's
where you're sitting partly.
The first day I was under
a vent and it was freezing.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: OK,
whenever you're ready.
GUEST SPEAKER: OK.
Few things strike more
dread than hearing
you have to get braces.
Whether it's worrying about
how much it will hurt,
what happens if a wire pops
out, how you're going to talk,
or how much your friends
will make fun of you,
it's kind of an
awkward experience.
So why even get braces
in the first place?
Cut to pictures of famous
stars who have had braces
with a voiceover.
Should I keep--
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Yep,
just the next sentence.
GUEST SPEAKER:
Studies have shown
that having a beautiful
smile with even white teeth
conveys health and youth, and
makes people like you even
a little bit more.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Cool, thanks.
Who were the famous stars
that you are thinking of here?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: But this
video's about you.
AUDIENCE: Well the
way that I structured
it is to have as
little of me in it
as possible, which is why I
had so much of the [INAUDIBLE].
There would only be
one or two choices.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Just
out of curiosity, why?
Why did you structure
it that way?
AUDIENCE: I like the
animation aspect.
I also know I don't
look good on camera.
AUDIENCE: No one knows that
they don't look at my camera.
AUDIENCE: I feel
like this is the fear
that every person comes into
a Science Out Loud episode
with is like, we
want to animate this,
because I don't want to
explain it on a camera.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Or I can't
say this long of a paragraph
without stumbling.
AUDIENCE: Or we'll
take their script away,
and they'll be like
I need to have it.
I can't do it.
That is so not true.
You can't actually prove
that you can't do it.
And we want your
faces to be on camera,
and we can talk about
this more, but I
think that if you do
too much of the pictures
and the voiceovers
and the animations,
then we go back to
that Siri litmus test.
Or if we swap you out for
anyone else to do this video,
it's not going to
make a big difference.
And I don't know if
you're OK with that,
but I certainly feel like
you have compelling enough
of a perspective.
Didn't you say you used to work
for an orthodontics company?
Yeah, that is a really
unique perspective,
both from the industry--
and my mom's a dentist.
So I used to work at her
office, and I had braces twice.
And I know for sure that there's
so much fascinating information
about that that you would know
from that perspective that most
people don't.
You can make a video that
a lot of people can't.
And I would hesitate
to let you go
on thinking that your
video should be that way.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: And
that's not to say
that like it's just going to
be you on camera or any of you.
That's not to say
the entire video
is going to be from here
to here, 100% of the time,
talking.
We know that that doesn't
make for compelling video.
You want to have the person
doing something, interacting
with their environment, being in
an interesting place, whatever.
There are lots of ways to
compliment the fact that--
let me back up a second.
The human-to-human--
ideally, you
want to transmit information.
One person sits down
and talks to another,
that's like the idealized
way to engage someone, convey
information, talk about
an interesting subject,
whatever it is.
Obviously, video
gives you the power
to do that to a wide audience
at once, and it's remote,
but there is
something about seeing
someone's face, and
expressions, and intonations,
and something that really
draws you into the material.
But that having
been said, you don't
want to just stay
on that person's
face for the whole video
and not show anything else.
But that's our job, as
producers and directors,
is to figure out where it makes
sense to just do a simple head
shot of someone talking
versus where it makes sense
to cut away for an animation.
If you're talking about
like teeth moving,
that might be a
perfect place to do it.
Versus where to do
a demo or whatever
it is to keep visual variety and
interest throughout the video.
But yes?
AUDIENCE: That was a
tangent-- an important one.
AUDIENCE: No, I think it's
actually really important.
AUDIENCE: Well, it's also
a segue into [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I have all these graduate
fellows who work for me.
We do workshops all over campus
and our biggest credibility,
and why we can give our
workshops,and why people care,
and listen to them is because
we give workshops on how
to succeed with the National
Science Foundation awards from
people who have
actually earned them.
We're authentic.
I did this.
I'm going to tell you what
I did to be successful.
That's what you have
that's so powerful.
I'm a student.
I'm studying this with this
really great institute,
and I'm going to share with you
how I think about something.
That's like the most authentic
you can be, is being you.
It would be a shame to go to
someone who's inauthentic,
like someone we don't know
like a movie star, when
you have this incredible
credibility by just being you.
That's so powerful.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: OK.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, you
guys are so cool.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: No,
you're absolutely right.
That is correct.
AUDIENCE: But now it's
about how to structure
the script in which you can feel
most comfortable being that.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Yeah
There was something
I wanted to say about
this, but I forgot.
Maybe it'll come back to me.
Anyway, comments on
the script before we
get into the hosting side?
AUDIENCE: I like the
first paragraph especially
GEORGE ZAIDAN: What
do you like about it?
AUDIENCE: I felt that
whe she was saying it's
as if-- I imagine her saying
this to a bunch of girls
in front with braces.
Telling them a story
about her life and saying,
oh, I used to have braces,
and I didn't like it.
So why do you want to get
braces? [INAUDIBLE] as to
why it's important or why not.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Yeah, she
gives very specific examples
about realistic fears that
people will have about braces,
and that makes it relatable.
It's going to hurt.
You know you've got these like
metal wires in your mouth.
What happens if they
poke you in the gum?
How you going to talk with
all this stuff in your face?
People are going
to make fun of you.
Those are actual,
real fears that you
get when you've had braces.
So, pointing them out
like that is effective.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Just to
check, is the content
of the question or the video
why you get braces or is it
[INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: The
actual video itself
is about what happens
when the braces move
your teeth on a cellular level.
AUDIENCE: What
happens [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: As the force
is applied to your tooth,
there are two different
types of cells, one of which
actually dissolves some
of the bone in your jaw
to make a little bit more room,
and another one that actually
builds the bone to be able
to hold the bone in place.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Wow.
I had no idea.
That's cool.
AUDIENCE: And that's
like the shoebox thing.
GEORGE ZAIDAN:
That's the reaction
you want from an audience.
What I just did--
I wasn't faking it.
That's an authentic reaction.
That's the reaction
that you want.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I mean
later on in the script
I say it's actually
dissolving your jaw.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: I
had a question--
so the braces are only
attached to your teeth, right?
So normally when you
want to move something--
like I want to move this
table-- my foot's on the floor,
and I push against my
foot to pull the table,
whereas with braces, I'm not
holding some external object
to pull teeth in a certain
direction, so how is that by--
AUDIENCE: Headgear.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Huh?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Headgear, yeah.
But most people
don't-- I don't know.
Correct me if I'm wrong,
but I think people--
when you get
braces, usually it's
just the metal and the
wire on your tooth.
But there's no
external support there.
So how does it move your teeth?
AUDIENCE: So that's
a physics question,
and we went over this yesterday.
Because there are
different aspects.
There's the sort
of what's happening
on the cellular level,
which is one approach.
You can also do it from the
material science-- basically
what moves your
teeth the wire itself
and its shape that's
constantly applying pressure.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Is that why
you get your wire changed?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: I mean imagine
being one person who
has two boxes on
either side of them,
and they want to bring
them closer together.
The external force is the person
itself pulling them together.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Yeah, but
the tension in the wire--
that's the--
AUDIENCE: Right.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] when I
had braces they had my molars--
I don't know if they're using
that now to the points or not,
but you had the metal--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: They put a
whole band around your--
they don't do that anymore.
AUDIENCE: They don't--
back in my day.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: They have much
better adhesives now,
so that was another-- the
chemistry of the epoxy
that actually-- I mean
there's a lot of science that
goes into your braces.
AUDIENCE: And when
you think about it--
I would have this discussion
with my mother all the time,
because I had to
have braces twice.
And I was like, mom.
Braces, when you think about
it, they're like barbaric.
I can't believe we're
living in the 21st century,
and I pay money for a person
to glue metal to my mouth
and take wires to
yank my teeth together
because I have too
much gap in-between.
That's so barbaric when
you think about it,
that your jaw is dissolving.
But barbaric in a way that's
fascinating to watch on video,
and I feel like
that's such a more
high-stakes drama-driven hook
than you're worrying if braces
will hurt or how you'll look.
AUDIENCE: It's interesting too,
because the bottom question
gets at the anthropological
question of what is beauty.
But really, I think
it's much more.
If we're going to get back
to the evolutionary question
of what makes someone
cold versus hot, and will
they die soon or
not-- if all of us
has evolved to the point
where 80% of tweens
end up getting braces, what's
wrong with our society,
and why do we have to
keep fixing these teeth?
Is it actually going
to make us die sooner
if you don't fix
your teeth, or is it
just because we look prettier?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Is it cosmetic?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I know that I will
at some point have
to deal with some more
significant dental issues that
are actually about
my functioning.
But proportion of this is
actually-- I don't know.
And I don't know if that's
a question you're even
going to get into, but why
do so many teenagers end up
getting braces.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: So that and
Elizabeth's point are related.
When she was describing
the barbarity of you
get these metal blocks
and a wire in your mouth
and all sorts of stuff--
what technique is that?
What is that?
It's not a metaphor.
What is she doing there?
Yeah, so she's
inducing emotional pain
by asking you to put yourself
in her shoes and getting this.
But specifically when she
says, OK, you get braces.
You're going to go
and have someone--
you're going to pay
them to glue metal stuff
to every one of your teeth,
then take a wire that is not
in the shape of your mouth, bend
it so that it fits your mouth,
and then it forces your
teeth to move around.
Like what is that
that she's doing?
Who here has seen
Robin Williams' comedy
sketch on golf?
Anyone?
Oh, you have?
It has a lot of bad language
in it, but it is hilarious.
And I can't do it
here for that reason,
but you should watch it tonight.
He basically says,
look, golf-- you
take a stick with a really tiny
metal thing on the end of it,
and you have a small ball.
And the goal is, without
touching the ball,
to beat it with
the stick until you
get close enough to a
tiny hole in the ground
that you can take
another stick and then
gently tap the ball into the
hole, not once, but 18 times.
That's the same technique
as Elizabeth's using,
what is that?
Why is that interesting?
Why does that make us listen?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Well
it's was humorous,
because you get used to the
jargon and different terms,
but it's the sort of thing if
you're trying to describe it
to someone who has no clue
what you're talking about.
it just sounds so
utterly ridiculous.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Exactly.
So the humor, actually, I'd
argue is a secondary component.
Really, the crux of
it is what you said
about being used to something.
It is taking something
that's familiar
and describing it from a
completely different vantage
point, and you can only
do that with things
that are familiar enough
that people are so used
to them that they just don't
think about it-- braces,
oh yeah.
Braces, whatever.
But when you shift
that perspective,
you do inject humor.
You can inject drama.
You can inject--
mainly humor and drama.
Humor and drama.
And you force people to sort of
step out of their comfort zone
and consider something
that-- they just
look at it in a totally
different way, which
is an alternative opening.
So that's another thing
that you could consider.
If I were to tell
you-- and the way to do
it would be to do
it as a reveal.
If I were to tell
you that you're
going to go to someone's
place of business,
pay them money to fill your
mouth with a bunch of metal
and plastic and chemicals,
would you do it?
And then like, no.
But people do that every day.
It's called getting braces.
The way I just did
it was not very good,
but you get the general idea.
Other comments?
AUDIENCE: I also
liked-- I was actually
with Andrea when
she was pitching
her idea to sixth graders.
And her first question
was do you have braces?
And this one girl who did-- she
was really excited about that.
Like yes, this is about me.
And then the next question was,
well, do you know what they do?
And she started pitching
all these ideas.
This is what I think they
do, but then the answer
was very different.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Sorry--
the girl thought
they did something
completely different
than they actually did?
What did she think they did?
She just kind of said pushing
teeth, whatever-- just a really
basic answer.
But then Andrea
was saying there's
so much they actually do.
And I thought that
was a really good way
to get into it, because
they got really excited,
and they started talking about
their experience with braces.
So here it's kind
of-- if you say maybe
instead of whether
it's worrying,
you could say do you worry
about how much it will hurt?
All these things.
Get the audience thinking
maybe offering their own ideas,
but also it connects them to--
this is something that I have.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Yeah.
So that approach--
generally, I would call it
the preconceived
notion approach.
So you basically guess or
know what your audience thinks
about something, and usually
that is either entirely wrong,
or parts of it are wrong, or
not complete, or whatever.
And you say you start the video
by saying you probably think
that x, but actually y.
Or z or whatever.
And so that is another-- it's
very different than the fill
your mouth with a bunch of
metal and wires and stuff,
but it can be just as engaging
and interesting, depending
on what the subject matter is.
The only difference--
and this is
where you've got to be careful--
is that when you're actually
in a room interacting
with people,
going back and forth with
the Socratic method is great,
and it is a perfect way
to get into the topic,
but you can't do
that with video.
And so you what you
don't want to do
is make that two dimensional
conversation one dimension
by sort of just stripping
the away the kids' answers
and just putting
in the questions.
It's kind of like trying to fit
a square peg into a round hole,
or the other way around in
the sense that it's designed
for one medium, and you're
trying to use it in another.
[? SEAM ?] And I know that's
not a great way of explaining
why it doesn't fully work,
and I don't necessarily
have a better way of explaining.
AUDIENCE: Isn't that why
Dora and why Blues Clues
are held the way
that they are, where
it's like a rhetorical
question, but they
leave space for the
kids to-- my son
watches and answers
the television.
AUDIENCE: And that's the
educational best practices
for educational videos
that I was talking about
on the first day--
that you acknowledge
your audience, that you
give room for interaction.
I will say, going
out of your comment,
and sort of addressing
the kids where they are--
don't forget about
George's point of talking
for the audience, not to them.
Because the overall point I
would say about the wording
and the set-up of this opening
is that a sixth grade kid would
be interested in
this, but I'm not sure
that their parent would
necessarily be relate.
And maybe it's just the way
the questions are posed,
or the types of
questions that are asked,
but there's a risk of
falling into this tone
of like after-school special.
I don't know.
George, do you have
tangible feedback
that you can give about that?
I can't identify
exactly what it is.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Let's see.
AUDIENCE: Maybe the
question of why even get
braces-- how that follows
this list of examples
of how much it'll hurt and
depending on the delivery,
it can really change
how this reads.
So why even get braces
leads me to think
that this is the type
of video that they'll
show at a dentist's office.
AUDIENCE: I feel maybe
what you're getting back
to is the-- this is the first
example that we've seen where
she's directly talking to you,
whereas the other ones, it's
more of either the voice
is different in all
the other ones.
This is the first one where
she's talking directly
to the audience,
and it's abstract.
You were using yourself
to say, this is what I do.
This is a boat, and this
is back to me, my voice.
And you were talking about
time travel and Stephen Hawking
as this third voice.
But this is the
first time we've seen
sort of an abstract you
in there that makes it,
I think, a little
fuzzy in that way.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: And I'm
not necessarily sure
that it would help to just
switch out the you with a we,
because it is a we, but it's
also sort of a royal-feeling we
rather than a-- we're
going to do this.
Royal, by the way,
I don't want to-- I
realize I'm lacing this
with jargon, but royal
we means basically just I.
You say we, but you mean I.
So I don't know.
I think this is a really
interesting problem.
Does anyone have
thoughts on how to reward
without going the sort of
dramatic dentist route?
Because I think
this is interesting.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: We mentioned
the personal aspect of it.
If you had braces, and
you suffered from this
and that kind of [INAUDIBLE].
So we can say how [INAUDIBLE],
because I experienced it
just as you might be
experiencing it right now.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: I
kind of think I'd
be even better if-- I know
you don't have braces now,
but I would almost want
the host of the video
to either actually
have braces or I
don't know if it's
even possible to like
put fake braces in your mouth.
Like temporary braces
that you could just
have in there for a
day and to just start
with something like--
AUDIENCE: They did it on Ugly
Betty for all their seasons.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Did they really?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, they did.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: I thought
she actually had braces.
I don't know.
Anyway.
But to start with something
like see the metal stuff
in my teeth?
This is called braces.
And you have this--
it's a piece of metal.
It's glued to my teeth.
This wire is bent, and it's
forcing my teeth around.
So you're kind of doing this
sort of dramatic dentist
approach, but not as storified.
And you are sort of sideways
hitting these points.
Like I've got all the stuff in
my mouth-- is it going to hurt?
What happens if
this wire pops out?
Clearly I have a bit of
trouble talking or whatever
the issues are, but you do it in
a way that is-- because you're
pointing at something,
because it's kind of a demo,
it's more conversational,
more relatable. i don't know.
That's my thought on it.
What do you guys think?
AUDIENCE: I was
thinking maybe-- you
know how infomercials
always ask you have you ever
had this problem, and then
they go into the details.
So maybe start off with
have you ever had braces
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: How much it
hurts when [INAUDIBLE].
So it relates back to them.
AUDIENCE: Were the braces
your second time having them
or your first-- it
was your first time.
AUDIENCE: You could
show crazy teeth.
AUDIENCE: David Bowie's teeth?
AUDIENCE: Any English person.
If think maybe we've all seen
the bubba teeth enough times
that we know what they
are when we see them.
But maybe many Europe
creators haven't seen then,
and you could start talking with
this horrible mouth of teeth
and then pull them out.
AUDIENCE: I feel like this
backing out a lot from what
we were talking about.
But my big question is why we
even have the first section,
because to my understanding, the
video is about how braces work,
but in this first section.
It's more about why
would you get them,
but I kind of get the
feeling that the video isn't
really about why you get them,
it's just how they do that.
I don't know.
AUDIENCE: Going off
that, I was trying
to do figure out what my
main concerns with this
were, and I didn't have a mental
grasp on it until you mentioned
[INAUDIBLE].
Because I haven't had braces.
I don't plan on getting
braces, so I felt really,
alienated by the you in this,
because I would probably,
realistically, turn this
video off because I'm not
interested in why people get
graces, because that's not
relevant to my life.
But if you posed the
question have you ever
thought about exactly
what braces do,
that's a much more interesting
to me and to probably
a broader audience.
And [INAUDIBLE] your
tone with whatever intro
you decide to [INAUDIBLE],
because that seems
to be what your video's going
to be about, especially if you
phrase it like braces
are much more scientific
than we think they are.
They're not just magically
mushing your teeth
into the correct
place-- there's actually
a lot of things going
on in your mouth
that people don't think about.
And thousands of people
have braces every day.
AUDIENCE: And the other
thing is I don't actually
think that the
point of your video
should be how braces
work, beside that's
an instructional video
that Invisalign could make
and has made, so many times.
I've seen them so many times.
There's no spark or wonder or
curiosity in that whatsoever.
And I'm not saying
that every video
has to be Neil deGrasse
Tyson contemplating
on the philosophies of
our existence or whatever.
But when you think about it, you
can be born with bubba teeth,
and we have the
ability to know how
to craft bones in our bodies--
your teeth are the only exposed
bone in your entire body.
And we have figured out a way
to alter that, in such a way
that we can still
continue to use them.
So it's not like
you break a bone
and try to align a crooked
finger or something.
We've loop-holed around
bubba teeth and the bones
that we have been born
with, and can actually
dissolve the osteoblast
or osteoplast
or get them to dissolve
bone and restructure it.
And we can manipulate,
essentially--
GEORGE ZAIDAN: I
think what you're
saying is braces shouldn't
work, just by reasonable--
AUDIENCE: Or not even
that they shouldn't work,
but we shouldn't be able
to do the things that we
can do with braces.
Braces shouldn't exist.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Well I don't
know that they should exist.
The fact that you can basically
blunt trauma move teeth around
and then your body
gets them to stay where
you put them is really weird.
That's something that
is-- I don't know about
if you were to break
an arm and what
the difference is between a
braces and a cast, for example.
That might be another analogy,
or simile, or whatever.
But it is bizarre.
When you said the thing
about one type of cell
dissolves the bone, and then
the other one re-bonifies it
in the right place.
To me, that's the
weirdest and coolest part
of the braces thing.
And so incidentally, why
does your body even do that?
I mean it's not something
that your body came up
with in response to braces.
This is an ability that it has.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, this is
in your entire skeleton.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: So what happens
in our natural experience
where our mouth would
need to do that?
Get a tooth knocked out or what?
Why can we do that?
Is it only gums or is it
elsewhere in our body too?
AUDIENCE: It's in
your entire body,
because you very rarely have
two hard substances butting up
against each other.
They have usually
some covering that's
mediating that relationship.
And then if something
happens to permanently mean
that these two pieces
of hard substance
now have to be in this
orientation as opposed
to this one.
How do you get it
to stay that way.
AUDIENCE: So this is more
about how the body heals itself
than it is about braces.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Yeah.
The word isn't even heal.
It's more like how your
body deals with something
it can't change anymore.
Because healing implies
that it puts it back the way
it was, which is
not what it's doing.
It's like we are
brute-changing our bodies,
and it's adapting
to what we're doing.
Did you raise your hand?
AUDIENCE: Actually, I think
that some experiment [INAUDIBLE]
basically to make
yourself taller,
what they do is they break
the bones in your legs.
AUDIENCE: Of your [INAUDIBLE]?
GEORGE ZAIDAN: To
make yourself taller.
AUDIENCE: So maybe
for one year, they
keep breaking the
bone in your leg.
Then they stretch it slightly,
like a few millimeters.
AUDIENCE: How many inches
can they [INAUDIBLE]
out of you that way?
AUDIENCE: I think it's like
an inch or an inch and a half.
AUDIENCE: Is it
really worth one inch?
AUDIENCE: It's really painful.
AUDIENCE: So they
keep breaking it,
and then you have to [INAUDIBLE]
the distance apart [INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
The point of the video though.
This is going back to
Jamie's point of you
hone in on something very
specific like braces,
but the point of the
video is not really
just this is what happens
when you get braces--
it points to this bigger
thing that we're actually
manipulating natural processes
that happen in our bodies that
are important.
Like your bones have to break
down and remodel all the time.
That is actually an
essential process
of dissolving old bone and
osteoblasts forming new bone.
If that doesn't happen,
your body can't exist.
That's actually an
essential process,
and with braces, you're
manipulating that.
You're tricking
your body in a way
to adapt to these blunt
forces that you otherwise
wouldn't be able to do.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: We had no
idea when we invented braces
that that's what was happening.
This was discovered afterwards?
Or did we know?
AUDIENCE: And I
think taking those--
what you were
saying earlier about
how can we do this and
what you were just saying.
We're manipulating
a natural thing.
I think part of
what you can do is
like-- I was talking to you
about how your teeth slip.
You teeth want to go back
to its natural state.
They don't want to be straight.
They want to be whatever
you're born with.
And how that-- I don't
know if it's possible.
You might be able to
take that angle-- we're
made as how we're made and
we're to manipulate this,
but in the end, we just want
to go back to the [INAUDIBLE].
And how this is process of using
braces as kind of-- at first
it can seem like it's
barbaric, but it's trying
to manipulate this process.
I don't know.
AUDIENCE: This is such
an interesting challenge,
because we were talking about
this yesterday-- how Andrea
is struggling with
the opposite issue
that almost all the
rest of your scripts
are struggling with which is
she has the very concrete thing,
but she's not sure about
the big question is.
That this is the example
for that big question.
And we're struggling right
now to help her figure out
was is that question that
allows her to use what she knows
about braces as a cool
way of illustrating
some very cool concept.
And I feel like most
of you are actually
struggling with the opposite--
you have some cool concept,
and you're trying
to figure out what's
the specific story I'm going
to tell to illustrate that.
And so we've actually got like
a reverse engineering problem
here, which is we don't know
what the question is that she
wants to ask that
allows her to tell
this cool story
about braces in a way
that that example is a perfect
example for this larger
concept.
And the problem right
now is that there
are a bunch of different
questions we could ask.
AUDIENCE: But it's
a good exercise
to throw-out all these bigger
questions, because that
gets you out of the
after-school special.
That gets you out of
why do we get braces?
You put up with this
trauma so that you
have a healthy, shiny smile, and
then thumbs up and end credits.
You don't want to have a
video that's like that.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: To
play devil's advocate.
AUDIENCE: You don't
want to have a video!
GEORGE ZAIDAN: I agree.
No, no, I agree.
I agree with you.
But you can play
off that expectation
in fun and interesting
ways, like I
would be perfectly
happy to start a video
as a parody of an infomercial.
AUDIENCE: Like a
parody is different.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Parody
of an infomercial, yes.
Yes, yes, yes.
I mean to do the infomercial
and then reveal it's a parody.
AUDIENCE: But you
wouldn't actually
go out with the intention of
the infomercial as your tone.
No, but we'd shoot
it and deliver it
as an honest-to-God
infomercial for the first 20
seconds or whatever, until you
establish that you're joking.
AUDIENCE: No more
than 20 seconds
or else you'll bore the
crap out of your audience.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Yeah.
And you actually have to go
a bit over the top of what
the normal tone would be to sort
of signal that you're-- yeah.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So when I
first heard Andrea
say that your jaw dissolves.
That kind of brings
up a lot of images.
There are so many
movies where there's
a focus on teeth
destroying mankind.
So there's Jaws,
there's Piranhas,
there's just random people
with teeth walking around,
and that's kind of
their main feature.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Zombie movies.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and we watched
a video about what makes things
creepy, and one of
the images was just
a teddy bear with teeth,
and that was horrifying.
So I think the idea-- so it's
just making the familiar thing
unfamiliar.
So you can even get away from
the idea of getting braces.
This is something
we do, but rather
start with this monstrous
thing that we dissolve our jaw.
And that's a really cool image.
And maybe you put
it on a teddy bear.
You don't even have to
associate it with human kind.
And then at the end, you
come back to the familiar.
This is what we do, let
the viewer think back
and say, oh, wow.
This is me doing really well
cool things inside me body.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: I think figuring
out other examples where
essentially bone is
dissolved and basically
listing all of
those out-- seeing
what the differences are,
what the commonalities are.
And then from there,
I think you will
have a better sense of what the
overall story or big question
of the video is, whether it's
infomercial parody, horror
at the dentist, bub teeth,
teddy bear with a creepy smile.
Whatever it ends up being, I
think you're absolutely right.
The challenge is you have
one concrete example.
One really interesting,
good, concrete example.
And the question is how
to get to it in a way that
is authentic and engaging.
AUDIENCE: The body morphing
concept is very interesting.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Oh,
that's the other one.
Breaking your legs
to get taller.
AUDIENCE: And because it's a
everyday example of something
that's actually
really bizarre of us
physically altering
our own image
for one reason or another.
And people have experimented
with-- in certain countries,
big feet are not attractive.
And trying to swaddle their
feet in order to protect women's
feet from getting too big.
And thinking of
what are the ways
we have either for
beauty or for function
found ways to manipulate
our physical appearance
at a structural
or cellular level.
Not just on a going
to the plastic surgeon
and getting them to fix
my nose [INAUDIBLE].
GEORGE ZAIDAN: In
a weird way, some
of the body modifications that
we associate with extremism
are the easiest.
You get a piercing,
you're just driving a nail
through your ear,
so what, big deal.
Braces, which everybody
thinks are like-- everyone
gets braces-- are actually
this incredibly complicated
biochemical process
that's happening
that's a team effort between
the hunk of metal in your teeth
and your body to reshape the
only exposed bones that you
have on you.
AUDIENCE: And it's more than
just brute force pulling them
together, but you're
actually affecting
the biochemical
interactions that
are happening within your body.
AUDIENCE: Maybe
start off with that,
like say the common
misconception of how
braces work.
AUDIENCE: But until you
know where you're going,
that doesn't help.
So I wonder if, since it kind
of feels like we're circling,
that maybe what we need to do
is either have Andrea or all
of us come up with a whole
couple of our questions
that the braces could
be the answer to.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: I
think also coming up
with a list of other examples
that are similar and simple.
AUDIENCE: And then maybe
tomorrow we circle back
and see if we can
better explore this,
because I don't know that right
now we're going to get there.
AUDIENCE: I mean we
have a lot of options
that you can toy with.
The point of the conversation
is that the point of the video
shouldn't be this
is how braces work.
It's a tool that you use
to reach the bigger point.
And the bigger point has
not been established yet,
but there are lots of
possibilities that hopefully
we've been throwing out.
And this thread of
body modification
is a different thread
than the old making
the familiar unfamiliar,
and I'm not sure
that you can address all
of them in a single video.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: No, you can't.
AUDIENCE: But they're all
possible options They're all
equally viable options.
I would say that on a practical
level, how that relates
to the script that
you've written here--
I mean the studies
have shown that having
a beautiful smile-- that's
a sentence that's explaining
why we get braces, but that's
not necessarily a point
that I think you should
eliminate from the video,
it's just a point that
can come much, much later.
GEORGE ZAIDAN:
I'd actually argue
that that's its own video,
because the whole-- this
is kind of this like
philosophical point that raises
so many interesting
questions like well
how important is a smile
to the rest of your face.
Is symmetry important?
Does it really actually
make people like you more
if your teeth are
whiter-- so that, for me--
AUDIENCE: It's almost
like a psychology video.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: It's a
whole separate video.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
AUDIENCE: Time has done a
whole bunch of different--
I think Time Magazine has
done a whole series on beauty
and the physical nature
of beauty and all that.
I think tons of popular
magazine have really
tried to explore this topic.
I always get nervous
when we say studies too,
because the critical scientist
in all of us is like who?
How legit are they?
And are they at
Harvard, or are they
at Podunk somewhere and the
only person in the universe
who thinks this.
So that's just something
that I always think about.
AUDIENCE: But just saying that
that sentence-- you can neither
get rid of it entirely in the
open-- I would get rid of it
entirely in the opening.
AUDIENCE: I think that if
it were me at this point,
I would want to
actually-- this is
what I tell a lot
of people who come
in my lab for a variety of a
different communication tasks--
is to actually minimize
this and not not look at it,
and see if you can come up with
an idea that this fits under,
and then come back to this
idea and see if you can somehow
repurpose it.
But the idea of trying
to repurpose this
without that bigger
concept is not really
going to allow your
mind to get there.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Yeah, actually.
And that leads me to
another point, which
is everyone who's gone today and
almost certainly the people who
have not been subjected to
this horrifying treatment--
you will all need to
completely rewrite
your next draft from scratch.
So when we say redraft
a script, we're
not saying like change a
few words here or there.
We're saying start with
a blank word document
and start from scratch,
because otherwise you're
going to end up with
all the same issues
that we talked about.
AUDIENCE: But if you end up
loving a phrase that you used,
you can do what you call
lifting a line, which
is to just copy and paste
that line once you've got
your new structure in place.
And that keeps you from
sticking to something
that doesn't really
work, and trying
to step it into something
that works a little better.
It keeps your mind
open that way.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: If there's a line
that really sticks with you,
oftentimes you will just, of
your own will, rewrite it.
You don't even need
to copy and paste it.
AUDIENCE: We won't get a chance
to hit everyone's scripts
today, by George
can stay until five,
and I can stick around as well.
It's about 3:30, so we
should probably do a hosting.
AUDIENCE: I have to
apologize, because I
have to leave every day at
3:30, and so I am sorry.
This is my moment to leave.
But if any of you need to reach
me or want to connect with me,
email.
I will totally get
back to you tonight.
But I am sorry that this
always the moment of the day
where I have to leave.
So awesome work.
AUDIENCE: This is also a
totally normal process.
George, your script
was terrible.
No, we went back and forth
actually three or four times
where she kept being like this
is all fascinating information,
but what is the
point of your script?
And as the writer, you
are the worst person
to like objectively assess what
the point of your script is.
So having other people
talk about it is helpful.
AUDIENCE: And it's a lot easier
to edit someone else's work
that exists than to come
up with it on your own.
So it's totally normal.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: I think we did
eight revisions of my script,
and I'm a professional writer.
AUDIENCE: What about
defining the point
before you get started.
Particularly if
you're doing a series,
you probably want
some common theme,
and then each episode
has a particular point.
Or I don't know.
GEORGE ZAIDAN: Oftentimes
you have a point in your mind
when you start writing, but
then as the script comes out,
maybe there's a better point.
Maybe discussions like these
you discover that you know what?
Actually, this point
that I was thinking
of when I wrote the script
isn't what I want to talk about.
This other point really is.
And that usually
happens, no matter
how diligent you are about
picking the best point that you
can before you start writing.
And again, it's a
slightly different process
for like purely technical
instructional video--
like Lynda videos.
Because I remember you
had emailed me about that.
I don't know if you guys
have checked it out yet,
but we're not going to technical
how to use Final Cut Pro, how
to use iMovie-- but
you can go on Lynda.com
and all MIT students
have access to it.
And they're just purely
technical videos.
I listed all the helpful
ones in the syllabus.
But the objective of that is
basically open your brain,
dump the information
in, and close the brain.
And I mean that in
a very positive way.
They are very, very
good videos, but that's
a totally different objective
than maybe doing a whole series
on time travel, because
there's so much you
can talk about that right.
The objective of a
series on time travel
to pique curiosity
among people can also
include informing them and
transferring knowledge to them,
but it's going to be a very
different scripting process.
I hesitate to say a very
different scripting process,
but the priorities that
you're going to have
are going to be a little bit
different than a Lynda series
for example.